you you know you mentioned in a
statement you said something Harvey
Weinstein about how everybody knew and
that stuff's gotta stop but but he but
the other side which I thought was very
honest what he was good for the film
industry because of the work and the
things that he greenlit and that other
people wouldn't have touched so do you
think that this whole scandal what's
happening because if a guy like him is
no longer gonna be making decisions
films like that are gonna suffer no no
you all know I think it's all really
really good I tell you what turned my
head it was about two or three months
ago I heard a couple of women who had
been called in to the office and it was
just to sleep with them and they said it
destroyed their confidence they walked
out of there thinking that they were
worthless that they didn't have talent
and when I heard that I thought that's
more than despicable that's a crime yeah
they didn't walk out thinking he's
allowed I hate his guts or I hate all
men it hurt them deeply and for that he
can't be in our business no need but I
mean do you do you think that like the
guy the idea that I'm not to Matt that
side of him a little bit the side that
greenlit the type of films that we've
seen greenlit before do you think that
aspect of it will suffer like the films
like you're talking about where that
most people wouldn't touch that he might
have touched do you think it's gonna be
harder to get that kind of work done
well the short answer is no but the
longer answer is who cares it doesn't
matter I mean we don't make another
independent film for a year that doesn't
matter we've got to stop this right now
it's and I think it's the tip of the
iceberg and I think the world would be
better if more women ran it how do you
how do you make sure that what's
happening is supposed to be happening
unlike a set like shameless where it is
a sexually charged show where you have a
ton of nudity where you know the
actresses on that show especially Emmy
Rossum is you know naked on half the
episodes like how do you make sure that
those women on your show are still
comfortable it's an excellent question
first of all our business is really a
great business it was five or eight
years ago maybe even 10 years ago when
you start a show they called you in for
a little seminar about
what constitutes sexual harassment and
as embarrassing and silly as we all
thought they were we do it every single
time so it starts the conversation and
you're not wrong on a show like
shameless interestingly I went into the
writers room because I wrote one of
these episodes a couple of seasons ago
and John Wells sort of told me this is a
rarefied air you can say anything
anything you've got to just open it up
and let it out without feeling
embarrassed by the fact that the half
the rooms women and the other half are
men and they do that and inevitably
someone would say something and everyone
would go oh my god how can you live with
yourself that you even fought that and
there's a long pause and then somebody
says but you know what you could do so
you know the answer is we talk about it
we talk about it and there are places
where you let it all go and you let your
demons out and all the disgusting things
you want to say and there are places
where it's completely inappropriate and
the bottom line is it's it's men who use
their power over either men or but use
their power over men or women and it's
wrong and it's a crime and we got a drum
a matter of our business